going on welcome to Street cocoa hello
everyone hello we're very excited today
we're gonna be playing pub G as the kids
call it player an orange battlegrounds
we're gonna play at Xbox even though
people say to play it on PC because I'm
a console gamer hello everyone
mysterious maded Lecter OG dingleberry
zero oh I've missed you guys and all
your exactly you're amazing handles
today I got a vault Tec t-shirt on look
at this long t-shirt
we're not playing fallout today we're
playing clearing the battleground so I
done messed up sorry boo buddy hey Lee
Rose mr. log hello
Collett tube you know what we'll see if
it's a fail or not now if you guys want
to play with me
my xbox gamertag is my last name which
is impossible to spell so let's start by
making me me you know you got gin from
lost here let's see here let's just go
with this dude doesn't look like me
pretty I'm pretty white you know I'm
trying to get a little color here
alright oh this is cool look at this I
got a half C half C thing it's like a
two-faced situation where half my face
got burnt off that's right
hey can you make me whatever the one is
on the right a bit bigger gotta get that
gray hair yo okay
let's create it boom we did it yes
confirm this looks exactly like me today
yeah this is exactly 100% like me that's
it now why my question is why is it
worse on xbox everyone is saying it's
worse uh hello Madeline thank you that's
right andreas 31 yes I CRO no drifter
yes I'm absolutely
what is TPP oh I see first person or
third person I think we want third let's
start off a third person
Oh No you know what this is gonna be a
problem notifications are on this is an
issue we've had problems with this
before guys it's gonna be hard aiming on
Xbox well you know what I have trouble
anything anyway oh this is gonna be a
problem we're gonna have to take we're
gonna need to take these notifications
off we should have done this initially
can I do it while the game is happening
is the question Oh
Xbox test Xbox test notifications oh
let's take this see we can get
notifications off this is a mess
displaying sound notifications off I
guess nope nope nope this is a mess this
is a mess we're out of here hey go
fullscreen for a second would you there
thanks I'm else okay well again add me
on how did it how was everyone's a break
and went out of a good break oh here we
go
oh yeah notifications off dude we're
back oh god okay we're back here we go I
don't have a good break hope you did
this so far this seems exactly like the
PC version I can still punch people at
will Wow somebody made this TV very dark
alright there's a lot this basically
looks like my gym everyone just there we
go the famous plain now as I understand
it I I never played this game I tried to
imagine Jordan playing Thank You Gear
har well we're playing with a different
console we play the different consoles
every time so I got I got to choose when
to jump out I don't know any the
controls I guess let's jump out now boom
eject here we go can I hit another guy
in flight can I hit that
oh yeah I don't have any shoes on that
was stupid
I think it tells you I'll look at the
bottoms of my feet there it's good for
foot fetishists don't want to release I
look out here we go let's release
parachute release it
we did it I'm gonna go for that
farmhouse over there already am at a
disadvantage because I don't have shoes
on so what's the deal with this game
that's right that's right read by Nature
where do we do it live a Jason Warren X
close game a great question
[Music]
hoping to shoot something very soon I
got a big ass Oh God
others dudes over there all right we got
to get a gun here or something cool all
right I'm in the house guys I'm doing
great so far look at this
I quit myself what's the gas gas good
all right I already got a go their
stuffs appearing next to me that's cool
I like to pick up bullet loops this does
seem a little glitchy oh that's good
pick up bullet loops
I quit backpack dude I'm ready to go man
got some guns I got a gun what else is
in here uh ooh
crossbow extended mag so what so explain
to me now what's the deal here what's
the play so I have to like start running
towards the play area is that the deal
hey big boy your dope I guess that's not
a little perverse sorry big boy oh
there's only 94 people alive and
dropping like flies already trying to
stay inside the player all right so
where's my look at this got a sickle I
got I got a lot of gas going on here is
that good or what do I use the gas for
let's switch the combat pants all right
which gun do I want oh this is just
gonna be me like switching switching
pants and switching guns is basically
all this is gonna be I like a gun with a
big old mag on it vertical foregrip
there's a lot of stuff in this I don't
think I'm gonna be alive long enough to
use any of this stuff
these games are all like five minutes
long all right how do we look at the map
that's how I look at this look at this
dude dude I'm definitely using this on
somebody that's a good battle or a Lipan
play you should try this game we're
going live you're gonna get stomped
you know what I'll be the judge of that
and yeah I probably will get stomped how
do I switch weapons anybody no here we
go I got the sickle I can't switch back
to the gun that's cool X maybe be B
crouches all right gas for cooking
perfect jump
the red zone is started where do I want
to go here what's a red zone so I'm
headed towards the I'm gonna stay in the
shadows such as they are um so I want to
stay in the player you're right where
I'll die if I get out of the play area
first you loot then you can stay out
stay out of the red zone oh Jesus
but I guess I have to keep going to the
play area right let the woman play
should be better than me that's true
that is better than you know you did how
did it go I love it
I'm running the wrong way ah this scheme
is a lot of running if she just renamed
this game player unknowns cardio that's
all it is
klaren knowns 24-hour Fitness Network
lag cool this is fun love this cool I do
love me some Network lag alright what's
the timer over the map expires the storm
will approach the play area what is that
what do you make this is kind of like
The Hunger Games only with all the
terrible acting all right I'm getting
there
so far I don't see anybody oh I like it
yeah this is great
I'm loving this perfect
well so far this game is really boring
now is that game more exciting on PC or
is there a lot of running on PC also I
like YouTube
I like YouTube how am i doing with this
play area situation cool Network lag
detected this is going great so far got
a lot of good Network lag I love this
lag am I gonna die because of network
lag lots of running on both when the
action happens it's intense
so far it's great at great action here
we go oh cool
alright now I'm in a different place oh
oh you're some kind of shooting or
something in the hell away from that why
do I feel like this is gonna be me
running for 10 minutes and then just
getting shot in the head I said storm
not knowing to call it here it doesn't
really matter what's called the effect
is it still the same that kills you dead
oh my god how do I get to this play area
faster I guess it's gonna kill me yeah
it's gonna kill I'm not in the play area
so it's just gonna kill me up I'm dying
oh I see a look on the right that blue
thing over there it's restricting it's
coming up behind me oh [ __ ] see on the
right that little blue thing can I run
faster than its gonna restrict it I
guess not
oh I'm so screwed I'm almost there I
wonder if I'm gonna make it well so far
I'm gonna be killed by can I see it
coming there's no vehicle anywhere
around I'm almost there I think I might
make it I got too much I've got like
three cans of gas this guy is a hold why
to holster your weapon run faster oh
here we go let's go baby gonna run
around this thing alright somebody did I
saw and read it somebody did a
calculation in like when you swim in
this game it's faster than Michael
Phelps like they have you swimming so
fastening the blue is far away alright
we'll seek X chill --ax put your weapon
away Thank You toke WOM goddamn big butt
yeah I will say this is beautiful
country yeah you know I wish I could
kind of slow down and take a look at
like the different trees and stuff I got
a life list you know a life list of
birds that I want to like see before I
die but somewhere in here something yeah
exactly
alright well alright we're in the play
area guys who made it we're safe I mean
we're safe now cuz we're trapped in the
play area with a bunch of killers so now
it's gonna restrict again right so I
should just keep her oh [ __ ] there's a
dude right there
ah so I shoot this dude oh cool killed
big Coach K should I loot his dead body
I guess so
what am i looting this guy's ooh dude
police vest don't take this I quit
backpack level two take this I'll take
this quick-draw bag sure first aid kit
gotta take that I guess I can't take it
whoo he's got a cool gun yeah quit I
think somebody's shooting at me dope I
don't mean bullets for this I gotta go
back and get this guy's bullets how do I
take it hold oh all of it
this is gonna kill me right what I'm
doing right now this is definitely this
is definitely gonna kill me what I'm
hearing right now is really stupid
everyone is probably pissed
wait what's happening here uh-oh
shits going down I need to how do I god
damn it how I loot the rest of this [ __ ]
I don't know
pick it up dude check it out let's go
pick it up pick it up pick it up can I
just pick up everything how do I just
pick it all up pick it up pick it up
let's get the F out of here man
oh well there's a lot of shooting
happening I'm gonna hide by these
barrels okay chill out right here for a
second let's see the weapons I got how
are you doing put a scope on put the
scopes on okay let me just reload all my
guns goddamn it everybody's so yeah this
is definitely the advantage in using a
keyboard I will say this game is holy
[ __ ] there's some too right there how do
I kill that dude
I don't do the scope thing tap left
trigger to aim down sight mmm Jesus
Christ
oh my god I gotta keep going ah all
right let's go more running
oh that's the bomb area
for Mike all right let's go
there's a dude over there I'm just gonna
stay away from that dude and run this
way oh cool Network lag I love this love
me some Network lag alright if you're
new and want to get right into things
you need to play with some friends I
know well add me I add Mia hell though
this is a death trap right here I'm
walking into a death trap this is stupid
I can I know this is dumb
what's happening right here never run
through houses there's a dude on my left
over there this game is just a lot of
run I'm kind of surprised so much like
just running there is in this game oh my
god
do I need it Oh what the I gotta go this
way oh no I'm gonna die Oh shite dead
I'm doing oh wow that hurt a lot can I
swim
cool I'm stuck here that's cool all
right let's go can I swim
that's better hope I can swim
all right let's go this is gonna suck
all right well we're swimming
somebody tucked in my spaghetti is in
big right well how was your break Beth
what did you do watch out for there's
sharks in this game what kind of sex
like that
hey somebody made like a raging bull
made a weird octopus that's bull we got
a floater even though you may be faster
than Phelps it's so slow his balls to
swim uh-oh
am I gonna make it to this play area the
answer friends is no I better get back
on the land I don't they I'm gonna make
it if I have to keep I mean but no one
else is swimming right so I guess I'm
kind of safe out in the water
halt and catch fire has been on the
waffle turrets Netflix watch list for
years you swim faster underwater how do
I go underwater
restricting the play area oh now I'm
definitely gonna get killed
look at how quick it's coming I'm
screwed swimming was a bad idea
telling you right now uh-oh Mouse when I
die are we plugged into the thing Xbox
plugged in the internet yeah so why'd
you go fullscreen after I die which is
gonna happen about 10 seconds it's
faster underwater how do I go underwater
oh here we go
what the hell I'm still gonna die though
look it's catching up to me I'm gonna
die in the water like I always knew I
would really here it comes look you can
see it on the map alright so let's see
what happens I'm gonna oh it's it's
definitely gonna kill me here it comes
here it comes here it comes I'm gonna go
underwater right before it happens it
will test this theory boom here we go
and oh yeah look at that blue field oh
no it is it is definitely hurting me who
said it didn't hurt underwater totally
hurts underwater how do I go back up
there we go oh I see it just continues
to kill me
well guess I'm gonna die hey lector I
could still make it run I'm trying code
I'm going as fast as I can which is not
fast no I'm gonna make it
I made it pretty good though 45 is not
bad yeah better than half my first time
playing is that you bad designed by
Ryder it's even more painful to play
don't worry
so alright here's what we learned so far
kill other people don't swim it's not
gonna help you barefoot barefoot is good
beer if it's good
ah get in the play zone I'm not gonna
make it to the beach yet fortnight's
good I'm fired says Nicklaus 42 we're
making it pretty good we're gonna see
what the number is 41 and 40 I mean 40
we died outside the plays in oh and I
fell suddenly I got really dense alright
number forty that's not bad
not too shabby
so it just alright so I killed one
person which I feel good about not just
yeah be alright you guys should we try
to add people now maybe to our team hey
uncle Rob UK yeah why turn them all
happy yes yes which is good okay we got
yeah what's that yeah I'll do that right
now
alright so add me up Blair ble y AE er T
on the old thingamabob and yeah wired
baby alright here we go so let's try to
act how do we add people here let's go
squad Oh three random teammates I don't
want to do that do a random teammate no
no
one-man squad well
I don't know how to add people in here
[Music]
do we like third person I like third
person yeah pretty good
please gave and clueless gamer maybe
[Music]
oh I see oh here we go
[Music]
scheme is a bit glitchy um so ah let's
see we had the main Xbox menu we do you
say with three friends playing here we
go oh great
alright how do we add them is the next
question who invite to my party invite
invite invite invite to my party please
invite to my god damn alright I'm
inviting people to my party do you guys
want to play let's play now to be fair
the last time I played with fans I got
them all killed so apologies in advance
a party's for chat oh right whatever
Alejandro SP no I don't have friends but
I have friends online this man face
please come to my party though be snack
oh god we gotta take that off for sure
oh sweet love this love this
perfect
creates all right
can I go squad with people I know no
it's got to be three randoms all right
maybe I can here we go oh my god this is
on another level I've never seen all
right
[Music]
maybe it's gonna work Lizzy let's get a
shot let's see what happens
yeah I don't know what's happening here
all right anyway let's just play this is
boring to watch and it's boring to do
alright you can go on the thing
okay um Batman
Conan is probably in rehearsal right now
yeah we're not doing shows this week
that doesn't mean we're not shooting
stuff and testing things for Monday
erotic support requests acts with a
squad q Scaletta selected show gameplay
after I've landed fair enough
you've been noticed five gears neither
did I until a minute ago
Henrick oh boy now would this be the
ultimate life and death fight I kind of
think not like the ultimate life and
death fight I think is what we're living
every day guys oh yeah that's right
we're gonna get philosophical here on
the stream you guys life is uh a bag of
peanuts it's real salt and not really
that good for you but everyone says yeah
nuts are not nuts are a surprisingly bad
free
lagoon's this says a lot about the state
of the cut of the world right now I see
you know what there's no option to hug
in this game there's no option to
high-five there's no option to
compliment somebody it's all just
killing and bad haircuts look at my
terrible haircut but also good fats
that's right bow chef X but I will say
in moderation very easy to eat too many
nuts all right I think last time what
happened was I
ejected out of the plane way too far
away from what the player is yeah so
let's see I mean we don't know is that
do we know what the play area is gonna
be we maybe just want to get in the
middle of the map right near a road or
something what's everybody's strategy
for getting dropped out of the plane not
spin all right here we go do about the
middle I'm gonna aim for that school
right there and eject eject eject eject
jump out of the plane
eject there we go let's go I also like
to do the there we go again I don't have
shoes which I don't feel super confident
[Music]
but I'm here to stay in the plane yeah
can you stay in the plane the whole time
the very end release our parachute
release release release Jesus I'm coming
a little too hot all right let's head
over here headed right for this tree ooh
what a soft landing like a baby's bottom
oh jesus there's already a dude over
here and I'm not gonna punch this dude
in the face uh-oh this is gonna be rough
I got to get a weapon for this guy and
kill this dude I'm not I'm not
emotionally prepared yet to fight well
if there's a gun or something something
already hurt me going or something oh
damn it 96 ah crap you know what I stood
close to that guy didn't have my [ __ ]
ready yet all right exit the lobby that
was rough all right so if I see a dude I
think my strategy is to run the other
way I'm not very good I need to I need
to like come upon somebody you know also
I think you know let's try first-person
this time because the last time you know
stream snipers on xbox that sucked
press Start to open the loot screen it's
easier oh thank you erotic support yeah
and then you just loot it up dammit hey
zo site team Coco plays pub G Lobby
hahaha well played North Horse shots
fired
I mean shots fire to me so this is I get
now why people just beat each other
because this is like the most action I
get the entire
yeah make this little brighter I feel
like you know what the screen might be a
little dark for me don't you think it's
a lot I think that's really I think
that's what's holding us back it's just
a tad dark so I can't exactly yeah see
everything I need to see let's turn that
brightness up give me some more that oh
there we go there we go that's what we
want right there that's that's the sweet
spot all right here we go
back light I don't know what back light
does but I'm gonna do it
Oh back lights great you guys I'm really
I'm really tweaking my settings right
now I'm sorry you can't see this but
it's only for my eyes here we go all
right so last time what we did with this
is just gonna be us jump out of a plane
for like an hour there's a brightness
setting in game too but I think the in
game settings probably pretty fine
you're going home Yegor I gotten a third
person again
god damnit where are we at here alright
let's drop somewhere this is gonna be a
bad idea I'm John I'm dropping and you
know what I gotta hit the drop button
like 15 times I just hold it bro there
we go
does everybody drop out of the does
everybody drop out of the plane quickly
or not
oh and that's it another dude for my
party over it let me meet this dude too
so I got to meet everybody but that's
the league that's the way it goes all
right here we go I don't know I didn't
see did anybody drop near me
Beth REE paying attention Oh Joe my god
oh no aah
I'm gonna run away I'll run away from
these guys oh I'm so screwed I need an
island where there's no one else can I
find an island where there's no other
bad guys or just other people sorry I
didn't mean to call you guys bad guys
let's get a gun get a gun look for it go
and look for anything let me just shot a
second oh here we go oh yeah dude oh I
got a big old gun quit the other thing
dude one died you weren't the first
today that's good all right I got a big
gun though now I get to third person
again like an [ __ ] I mean like an
idiot oh my god enough space not enough
space for more stuff clip helmet oh cool
oh my god this house is dope dude I'm
looking good right now oh this is great
alright there's so much crap in here
this is dope flash hider I don't even
know what that is
oh my god I got so much great [ __ ] I
don't even know what to do do I quit all
this stuff guys this embarrassment of
riches in yeah you know what you know
what's gonna screw me now I just got to
get to the place I think oh my god
there's so much stuff in here
alright enough [ __ ] oh and I'm not that
far away here we go oh this is my game
guys I could feel it this is the game
this is gonna do it for me
alright just can't get killed
I just got it I just can't get killed
here we go
let's be careful don't see me dudes
yeah I'm scared now cuz now I got I got
something to live for you guys this gun
that I got running the wrong way but
that's okay I'm running around
let's see anybody alright this is good
we're doing good
oh but I gotta swim again [ __ ]
oh that's bad there's guy with a bike
there's another dude over there so he's
shooting at me
[ __ ] it let's go get to this thing I
can't I can't let the blue area kill me
this time just run run bro run in a
zigzag not like Game of Thrones remember
when you just ran in a single straight
line like an idiot zigzag that [ __ ]
oh god there's some weird noise I don't
like that noise what is that noise it's
terrible
I feel like if I run down all right
we're in the we're in the good area oh
my god dude there's so much running in
this game too much running player
unknown alright we're doing good guys oh
it's an airdrop oh cool
oh so that's actually a good sound all
right fact that guy is gonna have to run
this way right so maybe I should post up
I see him right there that's a dude
right there alright let's go can you win
this game by being a pacifist and just
hiding the whole time probably there's
no way yeah
it's not running it's exploring it's
running Raging Bull you're wrong oh whoa
somebody's shooting at me probably for
that house yep somebody's definitely
shooting at me
zig zag zig zag behind this rock oh my
god after this oh I'm so I'm within the
player so I'm okay I'm gonna go find
some rocks and just post up I think
right let's see anybody you guys seen
anybody you have to go you have to kill
the last guy oh that's interesting
oh sure that's right there's only two
people left has anybody in the chat
actually won a round of this the feet
one challenge see how high you can place
while collecting no items do you need a
vest to protect my body okay
let's see what we write here I don't see
anybody you don't need her some like
binoculars sure I do some equipping of
stuff quip attached
attached to that okay lot of people are
claiming to have one and one a lot
really well I'd be lying
there's always no
all right I quit some stuff let's go I'm
just gonna keep running in the general
direction that I should run in right you
don't have much just keep going run to
the center and just keep going okay
that's what I'm gonna do I don't see
anybody else anywhere it makes me
nervous when I don't see anybody because
then that means that I'm the target but
if I see somebody else then they could
be the target oh [ __ ] I can't get down
here I'm gonna die
alright you got proof look at your
inventory for a scope go get vests and
scopes yeah that's probably a good idea
take a med kit that's good how are we
doing 66 we're doing better than last
time guys five so this is all
procedurally generated is every island
totally different hug the circle and
kill anyone behind me oh damn I think I
just saw like a puff of smoke hmm
someone's trying to shoot at me I can
tell that smoke or me being totally
paranoid that's the same each time says
Mtn oh that's interesting
I see so since I don't know the Train
I'm gonna get my ass kicked
same map same locations damn oh damn
seems happy over there
there's a car north of you something
yeah here's a dude right here
staying away from that car for sure I
just saw a guy like by the crest of the
hill here he comes when he sees me
Oh 60 he preserves I hear damn it
auto auto reload what does that mean I'm
at single-shot mode what does that mean
you got a switch to auto couldn't it
can't just be on auto
ah dammit alright we're going first
person this time
first person I'm a better first person
shooter anyway I've never been good at
this I've never been good at third
person I've always been better at first
person perfect clips yeah came out for
Xbox one that's single fire mode god
damn it my deaf don't want my gun on
auto all the time okay thank you hey new
FLE Nick hey monk
aim down the site ah I shouldn't stay
behind a rock like that when I know
they're coming on me take a potshot from
a distance it forces them to use heels
okay this is good guys I feel like the
last if I can just make it past where
was it 40 41 I think if we could just
beat 41 and the time we have left I
think we can do it what it's not being
better beyond single it's this pure luck
now how did this game become such a hit
it seems fairly simple isn't this game
for the most part similar to a lot of
other games that have come out like this
it's weird how it got to be such a big
hit ah left d-pad changing there we go
that stand up we'll other that's the
route you're the real MVP I don't screw
around with this you know what this is
all kids games you guys are all just you
know have your little fun playing
whatever I made it fruit to win it I'm
in it to be number one battle right now
good thing I'm not a mercenary yeah
that's true I'm a way better comedian
actually I'm a terrible community also
over our first-person mode now this is
way better I do way better at this I
need a lot of things I need a lot of
help I need squads I need a lot there's
already four people dead by the way
where people died in the pool hey so is
it good isn't what's these battle rods
made by people who made the very first
battle rail concept it is made
originally on the ARMA 3 mod Wow
Oh fortnight I might try some fortnight
all right let's just jump out let's get
out go go go
oh my god everybody jumped out
immediately oh boy
I'm going for this little farmhouse over
here do you ever find stuff in the grass
or it's just all in buildings oh I see
another person over there on my left
alright he is alive I talked to him
yesterday I mean as alive as he ever was
oh there's a dude right over there
alright there's two dudes this is
definitely has a bigger gun than me see
ya 93
I feel way more comfortable in
first-person and be honest now that
means I doesn't mean I'm gonna live
longer but I feel more comfortable 87
which way is this thing oh I'm in the
play area dope
hopefully that guy got killed by the
other guy who is over there I'm Way
better shooter misses in 15 shots they
hear the gunfire in the distance is
pretty intense yeah yeah boy ain't
coming after me that's good sometimes
guys better to turn tail and run hey hey
hey girl thank you
I don't see anybody on my six that's
military talk four on my tail which is
slang talk for behind me this runs
really bad on the regular vanilla Xbox
one I need meds yeah I need a lot of
things guns first of all I gotta assume
that this is full of people over here
right
Red's on I hate this gun only I was like
eight bullets and a better gun all right
energy drinks and painkillers open doors
is a good sign of past activity that's a
good call
whoa we got a lot of stuff over here I'm
not sure this gun is better though I
like this other guy awesome it's a hit
is a handsome gun
like a bigger gun we don't care about
pants what is this a fashion show path
come on nothing so far nothing also
we'll say every time you switch guns
it's really annoying the after reload
it's impossible no one's been over here
that's crazy
I like this glitchyness glitch games
nothing nothing
Jack crap
I have nothing good this blows all right
what's the bust I feel like I'm
definitely gonna get murdered in about
ten seconds rip chop peaches is lighting
it up there we go backpack isn't that's
not a vest though right where is this
town and why is there garbage and all
these houses clean up your house guys
yeah when you're leaving your place well
squarely within the thing I don't what
to do
I do I just run back on the old trail
we're doing good I just want to get past
41
am i running the right way here they
want to know the lure more items of
populated areas but more of a high risk
low risk areas have no items oh I see
okay oh I'm in a I'm in a red area I'm
in a red thing that's like bombs and
stuff right head towards the school you
say the school okay
don't just run on the open field all
right
what so I should Crouch crouch and run
it is weird how much more cut I mean I'm
not any better in first person but I do
feel way more comfortable so hanging out
an open field good or bad in a battle or
else don't go to the school oh dude stay
away stay away from that guy hey hiding
in the hiding in the wheat there are a
lot of explosion oh you know what that's
probably the bombing happening slowly
make me go prone often if you have to
you alright I normally go prone in real
life like at Starbucks school equals
death if I get shot I'm screwed well
yeah no no [ __ ] is this the school up
here oh really
you need better guns I'm not going to
the oh I'm far away from the school
anyway I'm by Yas Avani Pollyanna go
kill him you [ __ ] all right I'm going I
want to make it to 41 though you guys
looking for a movement this is like guys
this is just like that scene in Jason
Bourne only I'm the guy who gets killed
you can't use wheat as a cover Oh people
put foliage on low and can see me
crawling around ok fair enough so
basically I'm just crawling my own
benefit that guy probably didn't isn't
hanging out there right is he hanging
out in that building who's gonna hang
out is he right there I'm afraid to
shoot cuz you'll see me dine him not
with a pistol all right fine
it's a motorcycle here that's cool
hello anyone home oh Jesus Christ oh my
god
64 damn it oh that was horrifying should
just take the motorcycle damn it
alright well we couldn't do it guys we
couldn't get to 41 what can I say I'm a
terrible gamer yeah you're right I
should just stole his bike what are you
gonna do uh I've collected enough wheat
for one brick of your Vitamix how do you
like me some Weetabix guys thank you for
joining us we start back on Monday with
all new shows Allison Janney it's good
to be on we're very excited as well as a
bunch of other great people we also have
a huge surprise coming next week for
everybody we're very pumped about that
make sure you tune in Monday night we'll
see you guys right back here next
Wednesday for another stream Koko and I
got a new webseries dinner in a video
game tune in Friday night at 6 p.m.
Twitch that TV slash Aryan Blair we're
gonna be final fantasy I'm going to be
playing Final Fantasy and cooking flan
or flan is it flan so it's final flan de
see uh so yes watch that Friday at 6 I
will see you right back here next week
thank y'all for joining us see you guys
later have a great week bye
you